all right guys
bang bang i've got jessica here how are
you i am so well
we are doing this in miami you live in
l.a i do
what's the biggest difference you've
seen so far between la and miami
oh it's been so nice to come and get um
a taste of my
old life i was liking miami to santa
monica
yesterday it's so nice that people are
happy
and they're hanging out with each other
and dancing
just relatively acting you know normal
so it's like a time machine to come here
what do you mean old life like what what
has changed in l.a
um well i had customized my life into
something i was i was pretty happy about
um i mean
los angeles is pretty great you know if
you're if you're plugged into the
into the scene and beaches and um free
people and entrepreneurship and lots of
opportunities
everywhere you go and film production
and um
that's all done unless you're of course
any union so you can still do production
if you're in a union so
um it's it's just nice to come here and
live normally we moved a um a charity
event that
had been on pause for um 16 months
in hollywood and we knew that that
wasn't um going to be available to us
anytime soon so we moved the production
down here in miami which was nice it's
like 350 people
no no um capacity count
so yeah it was nice to come to sls this
is exactly what
uh the bitcoin conference is doing they
were in san francisco for years
and they've moved to miami because miami
is open and california
is not yeah what else are you gonna do i
mean it's a prime example of you know
money goes where it's treated best so
why
why would the charity not as well and
why why would bitcoin conference not
what's the problem in california is it
literally just bad leadership
is it like some sort of political like
um kind of consensus that's been reached
is it the weather's too nice and
therefore that brings like stupidity
like what like
what's going on there well it looks like
a
fascist takeover to me so what do you
mean by that
well nobody um the the movies always
primed us to believe that
that um a fish fascistic takeover was
going to come
in the right wing right if you look at
film um but it
it came in the form of uh left-wing
leadership and that was unexpected so
what are the signs that you think point
to like this is absolute chaos and
nonsense and like
this isn't gonna be a temporary thing
um well optimism is is a state of mind
that i
i had always self-identified with but
as an optimist yes so that's
been been paused you know um so i just
i don't i don't see anything that makes
me think that it's
going to go away anytime soon so you've
become from an optimist to a pessimist
and is that a realist
a realist okay what is the difference
between being a pessimist versus a
realist
well i just don't want to hold on to the
vision that i had in la to believe that
it's going to get better any time soon i
feel like
you know a room full of new yorkers
might tend to agree with me on that
holding out for threads of hope is
is just holding me back from beginning a
new life somewhere you know whether it
be
texas or florida i'm i'm only going to
go to a red
haven because that's just the only place
i can go
where i feel like any of my rights are
going to be protected
what do your friends think about all
this i'm assuming that most of your
friends are in the
kind of creative community in la or
southern california
uh the assumption would be or the
generalization
they're mostly democrats they mostly
agree with a lot of these policies
one is that true and two do they think
that you've like gone crazy
well you get a a certain amount of of uh
criticism no matter what you do
and i'm not particularly sensitive to
that so it's been okay i
uh it's hard to say i mean it's been 14
months now
of the red pilling you know yielding
orange peeling so
um i guess that it it's just
i've swapped my friends out i don't know
what to say i mean 14 months is a long
time you can build a whole new
life by then and that's what i've done
in business they call it rotating the
shareholder base
meaning that hey all my shareholders
were really into this one business
strategy
we're not gonna go a different direction
the way that we have to do that is we
rotate the shareholder base we change
out the people
from the people who agree with strategy
one and we find people who agree with
strategy two
sounds like that's what you're doing
with your friend group is to some degree
rotating the friend group so that the
people who
have different views you're just not as
interested in that anymore and so you
found new friends
yeah when you've determined there's a
problem with what's there i mean you
have to have some
intentional um
artistic freedom in your own life to
realize that you're you're curating your
life by who you
fill your day with and and the causes
you support and and the shows that you
watch and
you know i've i've all but turned that
propaganda box off
just it's a big youtube player for me
now so
um yeah so i i'm just it's not that i
willingly wrote off any of my friends
we're just not aligned in a way where
when they write me i just don't i don't
want to
see them you know so i mean i guess
that's
do they like understand that and like
want to stage interventions and they're
like hey
somebody go save her well it's
interesting because despite the
foundation you've
built if you go against the mainstream
narrative
it's dangerous for them especially in um
an image-based
industry like like what i do so
it just they don't they're not i don't
know i guess it's a testament
to the fact of how pervasive the the
brainwashing has become
so i've seen you tweet that people are
the problem but that also means that
people are the solution
can you talk about that a little bit
like what do you mean by that um people
are the
people are a lot of my personal problems
i mean i'm i'm
but also they're the solution because if
you if you
so people can repair themselves so they
can become their own solution
but also we're just here people think
that acts of evil
are committed by these um people that
are somehow just
straight from hell which is not true
everything good that's happened in the
world is done by
regular people and regular people also
commit all the atrocities
historically so despite the fact that
there's a lot of bad people in the world
do it well there's a lot of people doing
bad things there's also a lot of people
doing good things
so they're the problem but they're also
the solution how do you determine
somebody doing an action whether it's
good or bad is it just
how you personally evaluate it and you
may see an action as good and somebody
else may see it as bad
or do you think that there's like
fundamental or inherent good and evil
well i feel like i
a lot of things were less detectable
before
so but now that you know the fascistic
takeover is here
it's it's it's separated people more
so it's pretty evident to me and if i
think that you're on the other side of
that that i think is
detrimental to society then it's really
easy i can just
take you out of my life and so then i'm
naturally only feeding in and
participating in conversation
aligned with the people who at least
recognize the same problems that i have
it doesn't mean that we're going to
agree on everything i mean that's sort
of ridiculous
if you're an individualist at all then
you you
respect these boundaries between people
so it's it's not that people have to be
a duplicate life would be pretty boring
if everybody was a duplicate of me i
mean i already have me all the time so
i'm
you know welcome i'm open to other ideas
about things
but there are some hard lines that i've
just had to draw and if we don't
um what are we what are we gonna do i
mean how do you evaluate like what
information
to consume versus not i know you're like
a big fan of tim poole and there's a
bunch of other folks that you've tweeted
out over time
is it just you're scrolling around on
the internet and you find something
that's interesting and so you just spend
more time on it and kind of consume more
and more over time
do you intentionally go like looking for
certain type of information just
like what i guess how do you form your
content diet
compared to just turn the tv on listen
to whatever they tell you
yeah well like i said i turned the tv
off completely so that helps
and community is something you build and
curate over time and so of course
um i'll watch your show and see the
guests you bring on and then so that'll
make me want to follow them on twitter
and then i see the content that they
make and
and a lot of it's just my natural um
what i'm magnetized towards if i find it
interesting i'll give it some time and
and um so there's there's a nice like
home base like joe rogan's kind of
podcast home base so
it's fun to see who his guests are and
then go and follow them out
do you listen to him as much as you used
to know that he went to spotify
uh no there's a lot of questions about
the same way
controlled opposition uh just because
i'm i'm a youtuber and so it doesn't
mean
that i won't follow people off of
youtube um
just like you know some threats like um
stephen crowder you know getting deleted
and everybody um
getting censored so heavily so i don't
want to say that i'm going to stick with
the
with the platform more than the creators
because there's still
a rightness and a wrongness that i'm i'm
going to side with on that
um so i guess it was just the fact that
spotify only recently got the
infrastructure built to where through
the television
you could watch the podcast episodes and
i like watching it i mean he's got that
everything you know the studio and
everything is made is made for
consumption
to watch the video too so it's great
production yeah
so i just wanted that and and i would
listen to some audio here and there
because it wasn't that i couldn't have
it it's just not
it's not the process it's not i wouldn't
listen to rogan while i'm driving or
something even though
i could if i was particularly interested
so i'm happy that they
put the video back up the
whole idea of people being the solution
uh you've also tweeted saying that
uh in order for you to trust somebody
you have to know that they trust
themselves
i think it's a fascinating concept of
just like
if somebody doesn't trust themselves is
that another way of just nicely saying
like they're full of [ __ ]
or do you mean something else by like
whether somebody trusts themselves or
not
um i guess you could measure that in
many different ways
people are of course going to feel more
confident about you if you're confident
in your own
opinion i mean you you know that as a as
a natural born leader you can't
you can't waffle and you you can't um
add too much doubt as to how you
perceive things now it's silly to
say that people can't have the freedom
to change their mind because that's just
adjusting to the new information you get
um
but people discredit themselves with
siding with
things that i know to be untrue and
they're doing it just because they're
um you know little group are they virtue
signaling yeah
those types of things so when you
deviate from what i know to be
true as it's emerged in me um
i'm just not interested in giving those
people my time and attention because
if you're a sellout then why would i
want you so
it's almost like trust in yourself is
really the measure of like authenticity
like are you actually saying the things
you believe or are you simply doing what
you think other people want you to do
yeah and if people show me that they
have no integrity why would i keep them
around the whole world has
gone to hell because of the fact that
you can
buy everybody off so when i see that
i mean obviously we all have to make
money we all you know people have
advertisers and that type of thing but
i don't like the betrayal of integrity
to do
those things when you think about uh
the worst perpetrators of this is there
anybody who sticks out in your mind of
like man i really was
a fan of that person or i really
consumed a lot of their content and now
not so much yeah it's hard for me
because
um as somebody that consumes a lot of
content and got a lot of good out of a
lot of people
yes there were people that it it really
it really hurt
it really hurt to know um all along
i was taking information from people
that had no
integrity um but it doesn't mean i'm not
grateful for what they
gave me before because it was still
valuable to me so
i won't i won't really itemize those
people and i just want to i don't want
to say their names but but um
i do think about that every day but do
you think that the
um kind of giving up of the principles
or the lack of integrity or however you
want to categorize it was that more so
like
uh because they like sold out like
corporations and it was like
advertiser-based stuff
or was it more like political pressure
social pressure like like almost unpack
why they did it yeah it's all those
things um there's
a lot of writing on the wall and i know
that that people were willing to betray
beliefs that they they
personally had in their own lives like
dealing with you know communism in their
country of origin and then to come here
and get behind
that agenda when they know they
recognize it more than anybody so how
how dare you
when i've listened to you stand on
stages and talk about um
what am i how amazing america is and how
there are no excuses
to not go and and be your best because
of
their own personal stories like then i'm
extra offended more than people who
never got it to begin with you know so a
lot of this all centers around
information
um i think when we think of information
we think of what we're being told
uh that could be from corporations from
politicians from
mainstream media whatever uh if the news
is fake
imagine history how bad is it
like if we had to measure it a hundred
percent of the information we're told is
fake
50 10 percent
zero like just like how bad is the
validity of the information we're
receiving and like
that as a proxy for like how screwed up
we are when we listen
well i since i have been removing it out
of my life completely
um i don't know how to how to pick a
number but um
it i mean if we're if it's a scale of
one to ten of uh how
screwed are we i mean we're at an 11 i
think why so it doesn't mean that there
aren't still people
who are willing to put integrity first
and
um course correct as they see fit
um it's not that those people don't
exist in fact i collect them
on purpose because that's how much i
believe that's what can save us
do you think that it's an intentional
like rewriting of history
like let's take let's just use the
elephant in the room right uh there was
a pandemic
that pandemic led to this economic
crisis uh
we now 12 14 months later are already
being told
all kinds of crazy things that if you go
back and look
or 180 degrees different than what we're
being told at the time
so literally the world health
organization don't wear a mask
now wear a mask now you know hey in
certain situations whatever
you can just go point by point by point
and it almost feels like we're getting
like
gaslit to some degree as to what they
were telling us a year ago well they've
established that they're willing to
lie to us i mean i knew that i wrote dr
faucioff
when he decided for the sake of having
masks available to the people that need
like why can't you treat us like adults
obviously we wanted
medical community to have them and and
but to
to say okay well the crowd's going to do
this if we tell them that so it's okay
to lie to them like no it's not okay
you discredit yourself when you lie to
us i mean we're
adults who want who want everybody to
live like what
how could you do that to us all you've
done is discredit yourself as any kind
of authority
yeah what about on the economic side it
feels like that's even worse
yeah well i'm i for me i feel
that they had certain types of changes
they wanted to see
in the world and so there's a series of
events
that they set into motion so that they
could achieve
certain things that they wanted so when
you look at like agenda 2030 these
bullet points of
um you can kind of see the policy now
getting to those end
what is destinations what is agenda 2030
oh man
i feel like we've i don't know that
could be a whole episode all right wow
how do i even begin
yeah um well have you ever watched
videos about like the world
economic forum and and they're um it's
it's the
it's the communist utopia that they
dream about really
yeah there's ted talks about it all
kinds of and is
agenda 2030 like a written document or
is it just like
oh yeah no it's it's what they're it's
what they're trying to create
in the world and what is the general
like i should have
i should have came with charts and
graphs what is the general idea they
basically are just trying to become more
surveillance and yes and less power for
people yes
so it looks to me like all the
governments
are just trying to cooperate with each
other
they're not going to go to war with each
other anymore because i think
what they're doing they're going to go
to war with the people
because that's how they can ensure that
their power structures are never
challenged again
and with things like the internet all
that we have
really too much ability to threaten them
because if we understood
the truth we wouldn't want any of those
people leading us
do you know who dave collum is does that
name sound familiar
no he's a professor at cornell and uh
he um writes a end-of-year review
every year and it's very very long it's
you know 20 30 40 pages
um and he's just got a different way of
viewing the world
in it a number of times he talks about
collusion
and he says that collusion has this
negative connotation
right if i say to uh you that those
people are colluding
then most people will say oh you're a
conspiracy theory well it got
the word got a bad rap because of course
with um
the three-year very expensive lie about
a russian
collusion but collusion just means
coordination yes
so then he takes a step further and he
says a conspiracy
theorist is a negative term because you
are basically
uh speculating on something but he said
but if people are conspiring
and you call them out a conspiracy
theorist is not
a negative connotation you're simply
calling out fact you're calling out
truth they're conspiring
to do something and it sounds like this
agenda 2030 is basically collusion or
and or
conspiring between countries in order to
see
something happen and it hides in plain
sight it's not that it's not that um
this is anything that's not public
information that's what's so
wild to me but but when you see the end
goals
in mind you can work back backwards from
all of everything that the
the un policies and all these things and
why do you think it is that that we know
there's actual concentration camps in
in china and we do nothing i mean who
how are we the good guys
well how about that people can't
criticize them at all
you know for ethnic cleansing all these
things like i all of a sudden i don't
believe
anything that the left ever said you
know
i but it's like use that as an example
uh
undeniable fact that this is happening
as far as i understand there's nobody
who
has a theory or evidence that points to
it not being true
yeah yet we the united states is the
police of the world
do nothing about it well and i'm kind of
torn on what to do about that because
i understand uh the libertarian concepts
of of not going and being the world's
police and
and the um you know the entire
military-industrial complex behind that
and and the fact that that's not always
operated by great people that are
well-meaning
um so i'm torn somewhere between that
and the idea that
if we're going to do anything why why
wouldn't we go deal with that
well if we're going to drop bombs in
syria then we probably should go deal
with this
yeah it seems it could be something the
rest of the entire world would get
behind about maybe we want to
go liberate these people i mean
there's an entire and that's a should be
a bipartisan type thing that's not a
left or right
type concept that's just if we're going
to take this stance in the world
regardless of where it happens we should
be willing to
uh operate along those principles yeah
it violates
all i mean all of the principles that we
have i mean why would
why wouldn't we want to handle that and
if nothing else i mean maybe we
can't strong-arm the rest of the world
into anything we should
give that pursuit up but we could
economically
consequent those types of things but
people don't want to do it that's what
makes me so sad about
entrepreneurs that do these these deals
it's like anytime you do these things
with china like you
you're funding the enemy you're
literally funding the enemy why can't
when
i shop on amazon can i not search
criteria about i want my
um plastic crap made in india
so why can't i give them my money
instead i have to give it to china
because
oh that's miraculously not a feature
that's supported
what is the solution to like geopolitics
right and what i mean by that
is live on an island and make our own
stuff
is it something that a government can
solve or is it something that actually
the people have to just say look the
government cannot solve this they don't
want to solve this they may even
potentially be conspiring including with
each other
and therefore i actually need to look
out for myself my family
and just handle things my on my own the
free market offers
so many solutions that's why the
consolidation of market options is so
awful
for me is there a free market left
um well in theory i don't know what i
don't know what the term would be to
call it um
a heavily regulated manipulated free
market
what do you mean by that i guess i just
mean the options about
um incentivizing that don't have to do
with putting guns to people's heads
because
once now that we're we're um a
nuclearized
world i mean you can end the world at
any point especially because everybody's
got all their
allies so what are we going to do except
use the
free market well i don't know so i'm
from
i'm from the school of thought of there
are no free markets left in the world
except for bitcoin right and the reason
being
every single other one is manipulated
governed you know
there's something there that prevents it
from being a truly free market
uh you can argue whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing but it's
true bitcoin is the price
can be manipulated at times i'm sure
right people sell things buy things
whatever just supply and demand
but from a pure 24 7 365
no kind of external uh governance of it
as a market structure
it is a free market that's why it's so
perfect
that's why bitcoin is the hope that i
needed
does that guarantee that it ascends to
global reserve status
it it for me it doesn't matter because
i'm going to get behind what's right
regardless
of the likelihood it has of success and
if we could all do that
we could all make the world a better
place but people want to get behind
they people are are just obsessed with
being
historically accurate when well but
we're so powerful we
just have to choose the right thing and
then we can affect the outcome but
people just want to
gamble on what's going to be likely and
go behind that camp and that's
it's a terrible way to make decisions so
basically it's the trade-off between
bitcoin
as almost a religion or a political set
of beliefs or
some sort of socio kind of focused
effort versus it as a financial asset
and a potential profit center
yeah i mean i i came to bitcoin as a a
way to cope with the
depression of the reality of everything
i
learned the last year so philosophically
bitcoin is just
is just stunning and perfect and uh
there's obvious i have no base in in
finance i've had to crunch understand
the the general
nature of what's going on um so i don't
know how we get from point a to point b
but i believe in it and i am getting
behind it
what's your take on elon musk and
oh oh that's a tough one
i think the bitcoin um maximalists are
they have a brand established to be
defenders of bitcoin and they
absolutely have a right to take the
opinions they take
um there there's so much there's so much
organic nature to the way that
successful people
strategize what they're doing that it's
hard to look at it
on the surface and decipher everything
that's going on
what do you mean um who really knows
what elon musk's
how he's going to get from point a to
point b the path that he takes
um more times than not it works out does
it matter anymore
like what elon's opinion about bitcoin
is or the actions he take do they
actually matter anymore
well what i think of elon musk doesn't
really matter but hit
the value that he still offers yes is
still there i mean
i to me intuitively it looks like he was
just trying to compensate for the fact
that um dogecoin dropped real bad from
the
um disclosure on snl that it was a
a meme coin i mean i thought people knew
that you know
but i so i i feel like he was just
compensating for his
other things that he'd contributed to to
you know the sending it a direction he
didn't want it to go
he just wanted to recover some of that
now it's unfortunate at the cost of
bitcoin i mean we really don't like that
because we philosophically know that
bitcoin is the only
answer it's not a game to us um but he's
gaming it a little bit
so but but the i feel like he put in
there
he would put in his messages about you
know this is suspended we're not gonna
not
do bitcoin i'm not selling my bitcoin
we're not getting out of it
um it's kind of like don't listen to
what's he's too smart to know
i'm it's not like he doesn't get what
dogecoin is
and the fact that it's just a copy of
bitcoin without any of the
structural elements that make bitcoin
something that can save the world he's
smart enough to know that so
those types of answers are strange do
you think he actually understands that
of course i don't know of course
yeah i i would have said of course too
until saturday yeah yeah
yeah no i think that he is i think that
it's
possible that he doesn't
understand the um the fallout that it's
it's happening that's happening in us
about our confidence in him because it
looks like an attack
um but i think he's just dropping the
value so he can buy more
is what i'm so so that would be the
bowl case or like the positive outcome
here is the price drop they bought more
they come out they tell people that they
bought more
and everyone kind of forgives all of
this and says hey they were just trying
to buy more
yeah and i um understand that people's
people aren't that forgiving about him
in attitude um i think he's
i i think that there were the threads in
there he put in there that he used the
word suspended in
instead of you know i'm about i sold all
my bitcoin and swapped it all out
obviously the dogecoin like he but he's
also playing with his influence he's
measuring his influence and i don't know
if he plans on
you know launching a coin of his own and
he's just
getting some bearing for his influence
which is is quite possible
so what do you think about the response
from bitcoiners
like should it be a negative response
and like hey you're attacking us let's
attack back
should it be uh let's take the high
ground and we want to be your friend
i've gone through a whole range of
emotions about it and it depends on what
i'm
measuring at the time i mean my my
twitter feed is
is uh pretty schizophrenic about it just
due to
but but then i realized i panic my
intuitive
perception of what he was doing was well
i don't really know how to measure what
he's doing because he's
doing he's he's meddling in his own ways
and he's
sliding you know a game of chess that
type of thing and
um i don't know
i i don't want to write him off
completely if he had said yes i sold all
my bitcoin
all this and then led people down some
path about
trashing bitcoin i think that i think
that he needed a viable
he needed to make it believable enough
that people would
buy doge so so he went with the whole
oh big the old played out arguments
about bitcoin he knows that we use
renewable energy he knows all this stuff
like
how much more does a human being have to
do in business over 50 years
on this planet for you to have some
default mode to
realize they they do understand what's
happening and all that stuff is just i
don't know chessboard
types of things but i i will say that
it's extremely self-serving
to sacrifice bitcoin at least in the
perception of people that don't
understand it
because all those you know the new money
investors are going to go and
put their stimulus checks and doge and
there's nothing behind it it has no
solution why wouldn't you just keep your
trash fiat to begin with like
there's nothing there it's just fun for
people they're just they're just gaming
it
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
blockfy blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy in an interest bearing account
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user i think you will be too
when you go to blockfy.com pomp
again blockfy.com go check it out and
let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
speaking of stimulus checks
uh are we just addicted now to the
monetary stimulus like
can we ever stop this yeah well for me
all of this
has to do with trying to usher in
universal basic income
okay explain that well i mean they had
set the stage for it i mean
um andrew yang making it a whole point
of his
of his campaign um i mean can we just
call what it is is that not socialism
oh yeah definitely definitely but if
back to
2030 you really got to see all that and
you can you can see it
if it's socialism why are we not allowed
to say that it's socialism
well no i'm i mean a fraction a faction
of the democratic party wrote it into
their name i mean democratic
socialism is what bernie sanders is so
we are calling it that okay to deny that
is not very honest agreed uh
and is it fair to say that socialism
doesn't work of course
how i mean how many more accounts of it
do you need i mean whether it's uh
communism or socialism is a
is a only a minor distinction but i mean
think about
all the deaths in the 20th century
alone i mean like 100 million the body
count so one of the things that i always
go to when i talk about this
in terms of like socialism from the
government to the actual like individual
is everyone starts yelling and screaming
and saying uh well you weren't screaming
when they were handing out money to the
wall street firms
and in fact i was right right actually i
was saying that that was just as bad and
that was just socialism for rich people
uh and so it feels like uh all the
capitalists on wall street
actually showed face of being socialist
over the last 12 months but so did every
single person who was cheering this on
and
i just have this like um this vision in
my head
of like the historians writing the
history books
and they're like and look at this the
economist cheered them on while the
federal reserve pushed millions of
people into poverty well you can always
find
experts that will side with whatever
side that you want to promote i mean
that's why they
you can hire them think about court i
mean
there's all kinds of questionable
experts so getting economists to agree
with whichever side of the aisle you're
on is
pretty easy how do they miss so badly
on things like job reports and inflation
well they know i mean back to you have
to assume i mean
janet yellen and you know chairman
powell and all those people they
it's not like they they have some a void
of understanding i mean they're
picture original they're just told they
have a directive
and so they are trying to make people
not panic
they know exactly what it's going to do
and they have to seem optimistic and
they have to say these things because
they
need people to um you know
believe this is a good thing and this
administration is going to do a
do a good job for them because that's
who hired them and
the the most it's intellectual it's more
intellectual dishonesty which is why
they need taken down
the most insane example of this was the
job report in i think it was may or
april where they thought there was going
to be
a million new jobs added to the economy
and there's 225 000 or 250 000
well it's like 75 miss if every yeah
yeah they should i mean in any other
circumstance they would be fired for
their
incompetence like that's a 25 on the
test
yeah right like that is a big fat f
minus yeah like you may not get invited
back to class
yeah well they don't have to they don't
they don't have to
the federal reserve and meteorologists
they don't have to actually be accurate
for them to
sustain their positions i mean is that
the comparable
is the federal reserve uh central banker
is comparable to a meteorologist
i haven't thought that out but neither
of them have any consequences for being
wrong
and how many people get to say that and
still keep their jobs
yeah is it something where the federal
reserve
in their predictions of economic
performance whether it's jobs whether
it's
inflation interest rate uh kind of
impact whatever
we should adhere to the actual like
accuracy of what they're saying so if
you say hey i think it's gonna be four
percent
then is either four percent or it's not
or should we think of it more
directionally
and just four percent is higher than
where we are and so they're
directionally correct but the number
doesn't actually matter they've entirely
discredited themselves i don't know why
anybody would make any decisions based
on anything they say
there's there's uh press conferences
literally they sit there and people
analyze every single word they say did
they say the word dovish or not what
color is his tie
like i've literally seen these reports
that show
if they wear a certain color of their
tie or they say a certain word or
whatever
it's supposed to signal something to the
market which sounds [ __ ] insane
yeah it's crazy i would never measure
anything they say i watch it for uh
the the i guess um interesting insights
it'll give me as to how
how much they're willing to lie to
people
but that's really only just a scale just
because i'm curious
what does that tell you if they're
willing to lie more than usual does that
tell you that things are
worse better like what do you take away
from
they're just like the news media they're
just willing to support the cause
because they know they
you know they know who feeds them do you
want to know the one hill that i'm
willing to die on around all this
yes the financial media is a mouthpiece
for the state
oh absolutely there's no distinction
there's no that's state media for sure
that's why
i turned it off so in august
of 2020 i wrote this thing publicly
and uh those that were red pilled
were like spot-on everyone else
said i stooped too low i was going after
people
and stuff and what i wrote was there's
three types of people who create content
in the finance industry there are the
journalists
who do actual journalism i have a story
i go i interview all of the people in
the story i'm unbiased
i fact check i present it it's not my
opinion
it's the facts of the story you as the
reader can read it and you can determine
what you believe from it
there uh that's one end of the spectrum
that's the only side of the spectrum
that i'm willing to entertain
okay there's a second other extreme end
of the spectrum which
uh people usually don't think of as
finance media but i think you'll agree
with this one as well which is what i
call the
people with skin in the game or the
players in the market
so uh a hedge fund manager writes a
report
and it says i believe x to be true and
therefore we've staked
10 million dollars on this outcome or it
is a
person who buys bitcoin and says i think
that bitcoin is going to become more
adopted because abc whatever reason
the way that you uh kind of put a
distinction on these people
is if they are wrong there's financial
consequences
right so journalists have no financial
exposure no skin in the game but they're
doing unbiased
uh content the players in the market
they're just making financial bets
they've complete skin in the game and if
they're right they benefit
if they're wrong they get hurt yeah
those two ends of the spectrum i think
people generally agree with okay we
understand who they are
we get it but there's a group in the
middle and i actually think these people
in the middle
are part of the problem they're the
biggest part of the problem which is
they're the bloggers
masquerading as journalists right so
these are the people
who don't do journalism don't fact check
things they write their opinion
as if it is fact and then they publish
under
the title of journalist and then they
get cited as a source that's credible
and and this is how the lies disseminate
and how they
they're just oh this person's on our
side of the war
and it clouds the truth and it's it's
really too bad but
um you know ever since we reward clicks
truth is clouded the worst part is that
these people are constantly wrong and
there are no repercussions if you're a
journalist doing journalism and you're
wrong that means it's inaccurate and
therefore you are either fired
or you have to retract it and correct it
even retractions get so buried i mean
nobody really agreed but at least
there's a path to correcting the
inaccuracy
when you are a blogger masquerading as a
journalist first of all
the media companies are lying because
they do not put the opinion pieces in
the opinion section they put them as
journalism the second thing is that when
you are wrong there's no retractions and
there's no punishment for being wrong
although all of the news
is editorializing the opinion you know
and you get approved and put on cnn
based upon
not your ability to relay the truth but
your ability to be on
their side of the culture war that's the
credibility resume that they
so here's the best part of this whole
thing there's two specific
journalists that i'll put in air quotes
those journalists
uh work at a very large media company i
wrote this article with them and a
number of their colleagues in mind
they just launched under that media
brand a blog
a very well-known financial media
organization now has
two of their people one is a editor and
the other is a financial journalist
they said we are launching our blog we
are going back to blogging
and they are now going to go build out
this whole thing but they still
publish on the main site under the title
of journalist
and the pieces aren't labeled as opinion
and therefore when you look at that you
realize
that that organization has lost all
credibility because they are allowing
non-journalists to pretend to be
journalists
it's just another way to make a little
extra money and and
that's that's why the news is just
something now i
you give no credibility like how can i
it is
literally the corporate media yeah and
not only are they wrong they financially
get people hurt all the time
and they're complete sellouts right i
mean like that's all it is i mean
it's frankly it's disgusting right i
still listen to you because you're
willing to say that so
when you see a sellout you should say
that i do and then everyone gets really
mad
it's okay trust me i've been saying it
for a long time i don't care i think
that the
part that becomes uh a little bit
further down this path
is when you then say these same people
if you go look at what they're writing
they literally parrot the talking points
of the state they are a propaganda
machine
it's a it's a network that's
self-rewarding
do you know why they're a propaganda
machine why because the owner of the
organization is a billionaire
and that billionaire has financial
interest yes and that media arm
is there to protect his financial
interests yes
and and we don't call that out because
they hide and say we're doing journalism
we have a
you know a firewall between the
financial interest and our
our media publication but when you
actually look at it
that's not true and not only are they
protecting his financial interest
they're also continuing to parrot the
talking points of the state
which desensitizes people to what the
state is doing to what the central
bank is doing and when you get into this
whole spiraling out of control
you realize now we're sitting here and
over the last 12 months 14 months
everyone who is red-pilled who's in the
bitcoin community has been yelling and
screaming that inflation was coming
these same idiots were writing last year
saying inflation wasn't coming
yeah now they're saying it's transition
influencers right
yeah now now it's not going to be here
forever
even to the point of some of them saying
that when prices of consumer goods are
going up
or commodities are going up has nothing
to do with inflation
yeah because once you take the
intellectually honest approach of
knowing cause and effect
and going on camera and saying it then
people are like well maybe we shouldn't
print money
maybe it's not the greatest thing to do
so then they get pushback
and they don't want that they want to
just squash any narrative
of any kind of decisive alternative
opinion because then they don't have to
deal with it
what's the solution uh bitcoin why
well decentralized finance takes away
the power they have to
to do all the puppeteering that they do
all over the world and
run all these things and i urge
everybody to unplug the television
that really helps it really helps so is
part of this that you can't
fight head-on kind of the [ __ ] and
so instead you have to use
technology and build technology to
basically take away
kind of the wind out of the sails and
that's how you build a better world
is you don't go toe-to-toe with this
stuff you literally just say we're gonna
build a new system
completely uh insulated from all of this
nonsense
well you can only help yourself and you
can join the people that are
committed to truth so bitcoin is perfect
for that it's a it's another
self-sorting mechanism for me that's
been
um good to find people
who have other entrepreneurial endeavors
and sort of dive into that
or or find thought leaders in that are
inside of bitcoin um i never cared about
anything about economics but of course
i've i've picked econom
economists to to read their books to
understand
finance in a broader sense um but
bitcoiners because they are truth
forward people
and that really matters to me so it's
been a really great self-sorting
mechanism for that
is there an element of whether it's the
media traditional financial players
uh or just the average consumer they
don't want to see bitcoin be successful
because
it would violate their world view well a
lot of people don't understand that
that going against or not supporting
bitcoin
is just to stay um with the
power structure in place that are that
are running the whole world
so if you don't understand that
anything's broken about it of course you
don't see the value of bitcoin
you would just buy gold is that
something that can be changed like if
you just educate those people on
whatever absolutely
and they change their mind well they
have to see what's broken in the world
and for me
um i got red pill which led me to the to
the orange pill of bitcoin
so that's a path that i understand and i
see it a lot
um and i like it because i understand it
um yeah one of the things that i know
you've talked about is this idea of like
relative wealth
and even here in the united states
somebody who
continues to get pushed into poverty uh
based on the united states standards is
still
some of the richest people in the world
is that important or does that person
not really care
about the relative basis and they're
just saying i can't afford food gas
you know rent we're just so blessed that
we have no
contrast to understanding i mean i went
to india
and seeing it made me love america so
much
you know um to just see how much
the bulk of the people there don't have
anything they need and we've done a
great job
about resolving absolute poverty in the
world nobody wants to talk about that
because we have all this
relative um poverty in america
but we have we have solved so many
problems in the last decade
um what's a good example just the fact
that
i can't remember the actual numbers
about it but however many people like
live below like a dollar a day and
that's
come up to now there's a such a great
amount of people that
that are at least at least they've come
up to five dollars a day which is still
you can't live in america for that
because of how everything costs but
to have resolved the fact that a lot of
people now have clean water they can
drink and these
these kinds of things so i like that
there's some projects in place where
they're trying to get
phones in the hands of people in central
america
um so that they can be on the blockchain
so that they can have
bitcoin and work in their communities to
solve some
um quality of life problems that way but
there's
there's barriers to that working like if
they don't have
affordable electricity how can they even
power a cell phone i mean we've got a
lot of
infrastructure um barriers to
breakdown but we can do it that's what's
so fun about bitcoiners is they're
entrepreneurial people that
have can can have a bigger
vision yeah when you think about uh
bitcoin and the bitcoin community
is it an ethos driven thing like these
people come from all kinds of different
walks of life different education
different skill sets
jobs different places in the world in
many cases speak different languages
different religions different color of
their skin like everything is so
different it's such a diverse group of
people
but they come together and it's not
about a financial asset it's more about
an ethos
yeah i um as a person that
bought into bitcoin for the
philosophical aspects of it
it's just beautiful and that's why i
want to get behind their businesses even
unrelated endeavors how do we get your
old friends
to understand or to become educated or
at least to be more sympathetic
to this view of the world versus maybe
the world that they have
well they're just victims to media
propaganda and if we can't fix that
which is why i'm like okay unplug the
television would would really help
um for me um i remember i knew something
was wrong with
the media that they weren't entirely
honest with how they tried to
smear somebody like jordan peterson i
was like this isn't
normal because i my undergrad's in psych
so i had gravitated towards his older
content just him
lecturing you know who who can who could
afford that kind of tutoring so
i just started watching that and then
but then all the the social aspects that
developed around 2017
um the politicization of what he was
saying and just
the character assassination on somebody
i knew that
was a really good person i knew
something was wrong so everybody's got
to have those things
where they find out that the media lied
to them about this this or that and have
personal consequences for
um having believed the media because
then you'll feel that sense of betrayal
and you'll know something's not right
so what we have to do is not forcibly
tell people they're being lied to but we
do need to point out some things
when they say something you know you
could take the leading logic
to the end that they are going to
self-discover
that they're being lied to but you have
to do it without
you know it's hard because i haven't i
haven't refined it to an art that's
that's persuasive yet yeah is it
just some of this is like a political or
like a religion aspect to it and
no matter what facts you tell them they
just won't change their mind yeah um
you know locism is a cult it's a
religion we have a
we have a god-shaped hole in our heart
and if you take that out and you strip
that out of the culture people are going
to put something in there and they've
they've nominated being woke is this
whole idea of wokism
tearing apart the fabric of society like
is it literally pulling people
apart making it so divisive that
everyone is distracted with each other
rather than what the real problems are
yeah and that's how you of course
power structures in place turn the
people on each other so that they will
do their bidding and
attack and kill and destroy their
opposition inside i mean i feel like
the reason the reason china is unplugged
from
the internet for the rest of the world
is is so
they can't tell us when all these things
are happening because they they've gone
through
it and they you know they're never gonna
escape the ccp i mean it's like a
hundred year reign now
they have other political parties but
they but you know those other political
parties
aren't allowed to come into power it's
just more like um
a staged situation where these smaller
factions of
people are they're never going to
threaten the power system and in a
surveillance state you can't
in the u.s could there be a third
political party that could actually
viably put a president in into the
administration
um not unless
more people unplug the television
because it affects your perspective on
absolutely everything
so they have a dominance on they have a
lock on um
attention so how how could even uh how
could even a
libertarian ever get the the time of day
on
on the network tv that's controlled
centrally
they don't want that i mean they won't
even let australian economists go on the
shows to talk about
why the fed is wrong they don't they
just won't put them on tv
well just be a violation of the world
views right well they don't because they
hold the keys to the information in the
population
why would they um equip any type of
uh dissent against their opinion they
won't do it
which is why centralized control of the
media is it is just another example of
it's state-run media and do we need to
then build
decentralized aspects of the media and
have that austrian
economist or a political party candidate
or whoever build the relationship
directly with the audience
or do we need to try to go launch
national
television stations that you know have a
um kind of a liking for that type of
content or well i don't even know
how we would do that because you have to
then
be allowed to be on tv you know you your
network can literally be
unplugged your app availability can just
be pulled from an app store
and there's only two app stores so
everything is so centralized in that way
like what do we
what do we do i mean it's hard for
people to even be
youtube compliant and so they're willing
to be censored in a way just to reach
who's
you know out there that ca that can be
pulled from the mainstream
and thank god they do because that's
outreach still yeah
it's crazy just to think about how
important control of the actual
infrastructure is
right well and when you see it in
anything you can see it in everything so
it's all the same but you realize how
few of options there are for anything
i mean go to a grocery store and it
looks like you have all these choices
but like five
mega brands own absolutely everything in
the grocery store
so you think you have all this choice
but you really don't it's an illusion
and politics are like that like think
about um mitt romney
just kind of siding with the
establishment machine especially lately
so it makes me look at
history differently to where i thought
in
in 2008 mitt romney would have given us
such a different
america than um than
obama but really when you look at how
mitt romney is voting now
you see that that's still more illusion
of choice it's just packaging
that's different what changed do you
think he changed do you think your
perspective on him changing
no my um when you get when you get away
from it when you can tune out the media
telling you polluting your perspective
on everything you can realize that
there's no
there's no choice there he would have
rendered us relatively similar outcomes
i'll never forget uh there was a debate
between him and obama and they asked who
is the greatest adversary
and he said russia yeah and everyone
everyone thought that was so funny
and i think uh obama may have even said
this isn't you know
this in 1970 called the cold war wants
their policy back yeah
whatever he said right and now all of a
sudden
it looks like that actually may have
been a pretty prescient you know kind of
conversation or answer
how much of the geopolitical stuff and
the media stuff
and the financial stuff is
centrally planned mastery planned by
some elite group versus just
literally there's a bunch of stupidity
that is pervasive across these
organizations and so they just
constantly do dumb
easy things that optimize for short-term
decision-making well for me
all of it looks controlled
it all looks like controlled opposition
and you know who's in control then
yeah um the fed
this jerome powell yeah there's a lot
there's a lot of uh bankers in their
interconnected uh circle of of people in
place so it is just
everybody coordinating because they know
if they can coordinate
then they can't they can't be taken down
which means okay well then you have to
choose to not go to war with these
people that
are helping you out and so then it's
very cooperative and
that's why they're going to turn those
guns on the people and especially in a
surveillance state you can you can
contain all the opposition in a way
where you can make sure that nobody's
gunning for your spot of power in your
spot of influence and
all you have to do is play nice with the
other powers that be are you long-term
bullish or bearish in the united states
well it's hard for me because i love my
country
i just see the writing on the wall so
that's why i don't identify as an
optimist anymore
we've gotten so far away from our
founding principles everybody's for sale
it's depressing this is still the best
country in the world and i
am so blessed to have been born here and
there's nowhere i would like to go
so it's hard for me when with the um
bitcoiners and their bohemian
attitude about floating around the world
all the stuff that's that's all nice and
stuff but what about
what about america i mean then you see
how aggressive it's happening in canada
all these things
like there's nowhere to go so we can't
unplug
and and bitcoiners oh give me that
sometimes they're like why do you have
to politicize everything
well this was my path to how i got here
to know that bitcoin was a solution for
me so
my perspective is is gonna be
politically charged in that way
because it's a solution for me but um
if anybody can do it it's america
but i'm concerned if they succeed in
disarming us it's over
it feels like if we stay true to the
american ethos
and the american ideals can we get back
to it
we would be in great shape if we give
those up
and follow the path of where a lot of
leadership wants us to go
we're screwed well everything's
politicized now i mean the the
doj is compromised i mean what can you
pick anything that's not i mean we
we're not getting fair trials here
unbiased
media coverage there's nothing is is
untainted
so either we have a constitution that
protects individual rights or we don't
and all these discussions like i
immediately just
when when people when people want to um
pull the plug on respecting the
constitution like it's a hard stop for
me i mean i can't listen to you after
that
because that's a slippery slope like
that's the protection
that we love that grants us all the
other rights that we
have those changed or has it always been
this way now the internet has just
exposed them
uh it's emboldened a lot of people to
say that um
there is no ethical basis to the
constitution i mean that was a
surprise to me that that many people
have been willing to be like oh you know
america's
nice and all but it was uh founded on
immoral principles of immoral men and
and we've remedied a lot over time
through our
constitutional amendments so how can can
you say
that we haven't dealt with those things
the mistakes of our history
we've writed them through amendments so
people want to trivialize the document
but that's the reason that we have
any protections at all and so it's
really concerning to me that it seems
like it could be
a negotiated detail before i let you go
i have one last topic i want to talk
about bill gates
melinda gates seems to just every second
like there's something new that comes
out here
uh what's your take on this whole thing
well um people at that income bracket
certainly manage their marriage as well
so i i'm inclined to believe that people
like bill gates have been
living their lives doing whatever they
wanted to
relatively you know freely anyway so
um i think that it might be something
um people are forgiving about infidel
the public is
they'll see that and they'll they'll
forgive if you know but it's also
i feel like a distraction from the other
things that he knew
there was too much attention about his
other positions about things like
vaccines and buying up all the farmland
and all this so
anytime they throw something out there
in the media and they want to
make the conversation about somebody
like bill gates about infidelity in
their marriage or drug addiction or
something that the public is just like
oh well i relate to that that
happened to my parents or you know
something like this and so so then all
of a sudden then you have all these like
little defenders that are out there
being like
bill gates is a great man who has done
so much
philosophically for our you know all
this stuff about you know his
levels of altruism or something um but
it's all really just
um bringing the charge down
in us about what we're really should be
bothered by which is what are his plans
for the world
because they're not they're not good by
my estimation
why i
want to choose my words carefully i just
don't trust him all
like oh you're talking about who runs
the world
i just feel like somebody who
had accumulated all this money from
creating
a technology where he he created
the computer and then he created the
virus and then he sold us the
the antivirus like that's a template for
what he's doing with this which is why i
feel like
the pandemic was controlled on purpose
for vaccine industry and to bring about
all the loss of personal freedoms that
we have to get on the other side of that
for
them to be able to dictate every aspect
of our life which is what they want to
do
do you think they're smart enough to
coordinate all this oh absolutely
i absolutely i i think that it's
it's remarkably um unfair
to the successes of somebody like bill
gates to
minimize his intelligence now i just
believe
that he's built up the credibility over
time like what
what would i need to see to believe that
he has that level of influence
i forget who tweeted it it's not an
accident successful people don't get
there by accident
it's not yeah i forget who tweeted it
but somebody said bill gates is
uh the greatest rehab of a personal
like uh perspective of somebody right
like his personal image
uh or his public image has been
rehabilitated and it's been a major
focus and he's probably done it better
than anyone in the world well he can
financially incentivize
anything like what
element of reach is out of his kid like
nothing
that's who runs the world is people that
uh have that much influence and power
and
and um resources that it's unlimited
potential they can
recover anything the
best argument that i've heard uh about
all the philanthropy
is are you really giving money away if
you keep getting richer and richer
right now the counter argument to that
right and actually probably one that i'm
sympathetic to is
well you had been way richer if you
hadn't given away anything also
forming alliances and allegiances and
how could you ever do that better than
funding people in their own the things
that they care about because then
those people are all beholden to you
that's true and all he does is deepen
the powers that he actually has and some
people are just truly
uh they're truly just at heart i mean
that's not to be minimized
do you feel like you're free or do you
feel like you're beholden to
an idea a group a person me yeah oh well
the greatest thing about having been a
starving artist
all my life is that i'm free i mean
obviously there's things in place that i
hadn't ever really
noticed about but um i don't form
personally lucrative alliances that now
have
bill dictated my shoving money to you
under the table yeah no
i mean i uh you know drive a ford
mustang and and
live in a in a house with other people
you know what i mean like i don't
i don't have anything that i'm
protecting or trying to grow
other than obviously keep more money in
the checking account than i spend type
thing like i don't
have big designer visions on you know
these
empire levels of of self gain and i
couldn't live with myself if i
got what i wanted that way but a lot of
people
are and that's why i walk away from them
very fast there's a guy who came on the
podcast named mackenzie
from canada he uh lays like wood
flooring and tile
uh he's just what you would call an
average joe and that's he literally dmed
me on twitter and goes hey if you ever
want like an average joe
kind of citizen to come on the podcast
and talk about bitcoin i'd love to do it
been pitched us 30 40 times i don't know
why i picked this one but i kicked him
and said hey let's do it
he gets on the podcast and uh he's got
i think he's two young children and a
wife uh
he's so you know nervous and excited
about doing the podcast that literally
he has
his wife take his children i think their
dog like out of the house so that he can
do the podcast
yeah the whole thing right and we go
through the whole
uh podcast and he says uh a bunch of
really smart stuff but
nothing that was like out of the
ordinary and towards the end he hits me
with
is look all i want is a better life
for me and my family i don't want to
take over the world
and i think of that one sentence all the
time because i actually think that's
majority of people
well that's what's so hard about uh now
when you can sort of see through
politics more than i could 15 months ago
it's really hard to support any of them
because anybody that deserves power
wouldn't seek it
so that's why things that are
decentralized are so beautiful to me now
because it's uh uncorruptable formats
are rare
because people in power always
deepen their power and that's what they
built so i'm interested
in helping people build things that
don't centralize power
in every aspect where can we send people
to find you on the internet
uh jessica vaughn all the social
networking sites you can find me there
where do you put the most content on
twitter
um definitely a twitter addict so yeah
twitter handle jessica vaughn all right
thank you so much for doing this we're
definitely gonna do it again in the
future
uh i feel like you are the one person i
know in the world who got
red pill the hardest over the last 12 14
months
uh and it's cool to watch but i also
think you're willing to just talk about
it yeah
that's because i have a deep sense of
betrayal and so if you can just
activate that in people some kind of way
then then
um recovered liberals are going to be
better red pill um uh disseminators
of that perspective because we are
operating
with having been insulted
by what we were fed for so long so i'm
just trying to correct
all the things that i did like voting
for democrats for
a number of years anytime i think i'm
super smart i remember that it took
shutting the world down and waving their
hand before i realized what was
up and that wasn't very smart but i'm
trying to correct all of that
contribution to the world i think you're
doing a great job so
just keep going thanks for having me